- So I am at Rockefeller right now.
We are on the upper East side of New York.
This is my boss's office.
There's some historical
memorabilia behind me.
We're gonna talk a little
bit about history here.
And basically what we do here in this lab,
the lab is called
"Laboratory of Chromatin
Biology and Epigenetics."
If you guys know what epigenetics is,
you can type in one in chat, if you want.
If you don't, type a zero.
I will tell you anyway,
what I think it is.
So it doesn't really matter.
(Alexey laughs)
And I guess there's more people joining in
and basically as...
Wow, there's a lot of people.
Holy moly.
I just gave a seminar on Zoom,
there was like 40 people.
I thought this was like
the most people I've ever seen in a Zoom.
There's still more people coming.
Anyway,
so big picture here,
and what we study and what
we're trying to understand
is something that has puzzled people
for a century probably now.
Once they figured out
that genetic information is
stored in the chromosomes,
they also realized that
pretty much all cells
in the organism have the same chromosomes.
But cells are different.
So as the organism develops,
obviously, you start getting
neurons, and skin cells,
and bone cells, and blood cells,
and hundreds, thousands of
cell types in every organism.
But DNA is the same,
which is why you can catch
a criminal by DNA profile.
Or you can do ancestry by DNA profiling.
And your DNA is not that different
from your mom's DNA or whatever.
But the cells in your body
are completely different.
They do completely different things.
Sometimes these things go wrong.
And sometimes that
causes genetic diseases,
which, sometimes it's
a mutation in the gene.
And sometimes it's a mutation
that affects regulation of a gene.
And broadly what has become
obvious in the past 50, 60 years
is that what matters is not
just the gene makeup you have
but also how these genes are regulated,
which ones of them are
on which ones are off.
And how this on, off switch
goes between different states.
Development, disease, and so on.
So why does a skin cell
express skin genes?
Why does the brain cell grow
axons and become a brain cell?
Man, there's a lot of people.
And they're still ding,
ding, ding, ding, ding.
Okay.
So what people have started
working on a while ago
is model organisms, because
we very rarely work on humans.
Actually, now we do that quite a bit more,
because we have a lot of sequencing data
from human patients and
from different diseases,
and we can aggregate this big data thing,
But 50 years ago, that sequencing
wasn't really an option.
So what they were working with
were fruit flies and ciliates.
These little single cell organisms
that live in the little puddle of water.
And something that my
boss became famous for
was that when he and
his predecessors looked
at these ciliate organisms,
they realized that they have two nuclei.
You guys know what a nucleus is, right?
Okay, cool.
So they have two nuclei.
They have a micronucleus which
is very tiny and very dark,
if you look at it under a microscope.
And they have a
macronucleus, which is huge,
and it has seemingly a lot more DNA.
And the DNA is open,
and it looks like something's
going on in there.
And so then they started
isolating proteins
from these nuclei,
and they realized that
the protein composition
is very different.
And while the core proteins are the same,
they're modified in different way.
So what am I talking about here?
Okay.
So the blue stuff here, that's DNA.
And it's basically a very
long string of A, T, G, and C.
And the white stuff, it
looks like little pucks here,
that's the proteins we work on.
And they're called histones.
Who has heard of histones?
Yes, no? One in chat?
Anybody?
Yes. Two.
Excellent.
So histones are very small proteins
that are super conserved.
Basically, you can find them...
The same histones in you
and in a potato and in a
cow and in a fruit fly.
And for the most part, they
are pretty much identical.
And because everything in
science is informed by evolution,
at least in biological science.
If something is very
conserved between a jellyfish
and the human, it means
it's really important.
Like wow, important.
So when they started
looking at these proteins,
and it was back in the day,
like dark ages of science,
you couldn't just send
everything to a core facility,
get the sequence back and
get the results in the day.
You had to run everything by yourself.
You couldn't buy kits.
You had to make your
reagents yourself, too.
They started sequencing
these proteins by hand.
And they, basically,
started realizing that,
"Oh my god, these proteins
are super conserved.
They must be super boring," right?
Wow. Super boring.
Who cares about the protein
that is like a potato protein
and the human protein?
They're identical. Who
wants to study that?
Because everybody was studying DNA.
Watson and Crick just
published the DNA structure,
and that was the thing.
Histones were thought
to be incredibly boring,
just packaging material that
DNA seems to wrap around.
Who cares?
Until they did the studies is
in these ciliate organisms,
little micronucleus, macronucleus.
They're called Tetrahymena in Latin.
And these ciliates happened
to have these two nuclei.
And in one nucleus, histones
carried one kind of mark.
And I'll explain what that means.
And then the other nucleus,
they carry the different kind of marks.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, it turns out that
in the micronucleus,
which is tiny, dark.
It doesn't do anything.
Histones carried something
called methylation on them.
You guys know chemistry
probably better than I do.
You're like super, high
achieving students.
So what they were able to deduce
is that a lot of histones
in that dark nucleus,
carry the post-translational
modification on them,
which means that the protein is the same
but there is a tiny little
chemical group sitting
on one of the amino acids.
And micronucleus was
very heavily methylated,
whereas in the macronucleus
which is transcriptionally
active and it does a lot stuff,
the histones carried another mark.
And that was acetylation.
And that's when things
started falling into place
for the histones and
their role in biology.
And behind me, I don't know
how much you guys can see that,
there's this super ancient whiteboard.
And the sequences on this whiteboard
are actually tails of four histones.
There are four histone proteins.
And inside the nucleosome,
there is two of each.
So it's an octamer.
It's eight proteins
that all fold together.
And what people started noticing,
including the guy who I work for now,
is that these lysines
or quite a few other amino acids there,
they carry these marks
Acyl. Oh, camera.
Acyl, methyl.
And depending on where these marks are
and which marks they are, the
genes are either on or off.
And that became a huge breakthrough
in understanding both
the function of histones,
and also, generally, regulation of genes.
Because now we're thinking
about not just DNA...
Oh, I didn't shut the door to the office.
Because now we're not just
talking about naked DNA,
and all of a sudden,
you have all these genes
and they seem to be doing the same stuff.
But how come some of them are
on and some of them are off?
Well, it turns out that
the genes that are off
are decorated by this
mark, broadly speaking.
And genes that are on
are decorated by this
mark, broadly speaking.
And, of course, that opened
up a bunch of other questions.
Like why? Who does this?
Who puts these marks on? Who
puts those other marks on?
How do these writing enzymes...
They call them writers.
How these reading enzymes,
how do they get there?
How do they know which genes
to decorate the right way
or whatever?
And to be honest, we don't
know all the answers.
I shared a couple of papers with you,
and feel free to look through them,
if you want more in-depth
understanding of this.
Again, in chat, who read anything?
Did anybody look through this?
It's okay if you didn't.
But this became the era of
what's called epigenetics
and we're still in that era.
It's still a very hot topic, I think.
So epi means above, over, on top of.
And genetics means, you know, genetics.
So epigenetics means regulation above DNA.
So what regulates the function of genes?
What regulates the gene
expression, basically.
Epigenetic processes.
And some people take this
term quite seriously.
They actually think that
epigenetics means inheritance.
And maybe some of it is true.
We still don't have
the definitive evidence
of what's called epigenetic inheritance
in higher organisms.
In organisms like worms, and
sometimes maybe fruit flies,
maybe yeast,
changes to histone modifications
can propagate over many generations.
So for example, a worm raised
on certain kinds of food,
if it gets used to that kind of food,
it's offspring; it's
children of their children,
their children of their children,
of two or three or four;
they will have same modifications
over the same sets of genes.
When people discovered it, it was like,
"Oh my god, we figured it out.
We figured out non-Mendelian inheritance."
That's like a holy grail of epigenetics,
to figure out non-Mendelian
inheritance patterns.
It doesn't seem to hold true in humans.
Also, we don't really have
enough data in humans.
And also you can't really dissect humans
for your studies with every generation.
It's a little more complicated.
But one thing we do study a lot,
and one thing that our lab
has studying a lot lately
is human diseases.
And specifically...
Something happened in the last 10 years
in biological sciences.
And I don't know, does
anybody want to take a guess?
So what was the biggest
breakthrough in the last 10 years
that basically changed our lives forever?
And it's not CRISPR. CRISPR is cool.
All right, Peter.
Just go ahead and unmute yourselves.
- [Peter] The human genome was decoded.
- Human genome. Yes, absolutely.
That's a great guess.
And I was kind of going that way.
I was just gonna say,
genome-wide sequencing.
The next generation sequencing.
Does that mean you're raising your hand
or does it mean you are?
I have...
Odaelys, so I have your...
Oh, that's a clap, I
get it. Okay, I get it.
See, I'm terrible at Zoom.
I don't Zoom very well.
So, right. Next gen sequencing.
To be honest, the human genome,
they started the human genome with gels.
They were sequencing with gels.
And when they started it,
the people who were
criticizing that project
thought that the people were insane.
Like it's gonna take hundreds of years,
and millions and trillions
of hours, and dollars,
and thousands of people to do that.
And now we can sequence human
genome in like the afternoon.
I can do it right here like it's nothing.
How far we went is absolutely amazing.
And that's basically what happened.
Now it's a no-brainer, if you
have a tumor in a patient,
to take the tumor and sequence it.
It's a no-brainer if you have a patient
with developmental disorder
to sequence that patient.
And as our numbers of
sequenced patients grow,
what happens is we can
start seeing the patterns.
Because you only have five patients,
if you only have five tumors,
you can't really see
very much of anything.
That's why NFL games are so unpredictable,
because there's only 16
of them in the season.
And it's a small number,
you can't really make any
long-term predictions over it.
If you're sequencing
thousands and thousands
and thousands of patients,
essentially every month,
over the course of five years,
you're gonna accumulate enough data
to start seeing patterns.
And what I'm talking about here...
And it's very relevant to cancer,
but it also applies to
developmental disorders,
schizophrenia, autism, you name it.
Anything.
What I'm gonna show you here kind of
like a little explanation
of what this means.
So we take the tumor and
we take normal cells.
Normal cells are usually
just peripheral blood cells,
or you can take them from
the tumor biopsy as well.
And then you sequence both.
And if you noticed,
I basically compiled a list of mutations.
So on this side, there's these lines
and the vertical lines basically
mean there's a mutation
in that position.
And no genome is completely
free of differences
from reference.
Every one of us is different.
By every thousand basis,
there is a mutation.
So it's really important to do this,
control the normal cells.
But then if you compare normal
cells from the same patient
to the tumor cells in that same patient,
very likely, you're gonna
start seeing differences.
And these differences are
usually numbering and hundreds,
if not thousands.
But if you do more than five patients,
you can start seeing really
interesting patterns.
And these patterns can be like this.
For example, you can have
a protein in a tumor.
So I drew out here a
structure of a protein.
And all of a sudden, in this position,
we have lots of patients
who have mutations.
So what does that tell you?
Somebody, anybody.
Unmute yourself.
- [Student] That if there's a
lot of mutations in that area,
then that might be the
direct cause of the tumor.
- Yeah, that's a good guess.
It tells you that that's
probably important, right?
That's something to look at.
You don't know the direct cause yet,
but that's a very good guess.
And if you see something
like that, that's wow.
That's really cool. That's promising.
You want to study that.
You can also start seeing that...
Let's say, every patient
with that particular tumor
has a mutation in the protein.
But mutations are randomly
distributed in that one protein.
And that also tells you something.
Like this, in the first case scenario,
this tells you that this particular domain
or this particular area of the
protein is really important.
There are proteins like that in cancer.
This is the second case scenario,
which tells you that
it's maybe not a domain
of a protein that's important,
but the protein itself is
really, really important.
And any mutation in this protein
can be very detrimental to the patient.
And probably not quite...
It's actually the opposite.
Very beneficial to the tumor
because it makes the tumor grow.
If you guys could have heard
about a protein called p53.
You probably heard about p53.
So p53 looks like this.
It's mutated in half of all cancers
and mutations are all over the place.
If you heard about the protein called Ras.
It's also mutated in, I don't
know, 30, 40% of all cancers.
It looks like this. In fact,
it doesn't even look like that.
It looks just like one mutation.
That one mutation is just so detrimental,
so terrible that you can get cancer.
You can get another kind of mutation,
and that's the other way around,
you can have basically
blank areas in the proteins.
And that tells you that that part
of the protein is just
important for viability.
You can not have that part mutated.
Going back to the histones.
Why are histones conserved
between potatoes and humans?
Well, it's because they're so
important that any mutation
in these proteins is
very poorly tolerated.
And you don't get any benefits
from having that mutation.
So evolution is always
in our back of our minds.
We always think about
what is the pressures,
what is the benefits of this mutation,
why does this mutation exists.
All right.
Tell me something you guys want
to know in the next minute.
I'm gonna take a little break talking,
and maybe you guys can tell me,
what do you know about epigenetics,
what do you know about histones,
what do you know about cancer biology.
And if I can answer any of your questions.
And after that,
I will go back, talking
about histone mutations.
And then we're gonna take a
little tour around the lab.
Because, actually, it's like already 10:30
and time flies real fast.
Does that sound good?
Okay. All right.
So each one of you, go
ahead and unmute yourselves,
and maybe ask me questions.
Maybe I can tell you
how I came to this lab.
Yeah, there we go.
There's like 40 of you guys. Come on.
You probably have questions.
- Well, so I was reading
the just the overview
of what you guys do in this lab on the...
And it says at the beginning...
Like it mentioned some enzymatic
processes at the beginning.
And I would just like
to know, what are these?
Like acyletation, methylation,
phosphorylation, and...
- And everything.
Yeah. So how deep do you
want me to go on this?
All right, so we can go pretty deep.
So when we talk about histones,
and when we talk about
all enzymatic processes
and the whole concept of these
in biology that we study is...
there's this pretty artificial
division between readers,
writers, and erasers, right?
And it's artificial, because
the same enzyme can be a reader
and an eraser and maybe a writer too.
And if you're writing a mark above a mark,
then you are also an eraser
and reader and writer
at the same time.
'Cause you have to figure
all these marks out
at the same time.
So what happens with
histones and what happens
with our genome that's
packaged by histones,
is that histones are decorated
by dozens, if not hundreds
of different enzymatic
modifications on them.
And the enzymes that do that obviously
have to come to the right
place at the right time,
put this mark, and then
either leave or move on
to the next unit.
'Cause this is really
what chromatin looks like.
People who have studied this
using electron microscopes many years ago,
they've realized that it
looks like beads on a string,
and the beads are nucleosomes
and the string is DNA.
And basically, DNA is
wrapped around nucleosomes,
and it's interpreted by the cell,
in context of these nucleosomes.
So these enzymes that work on DNA,
we don't have a lot of high
quality imaging studies on them.
So if you guys wanna ever
go ahead and do that,
that'd be super cool.
I'm sure technology will catch up.
They have to go from one
nucleosome to another,
and they have to modify
them in certain ways.
Let me just share a screen
with you real quick.
Share screen.
So this is the structure.
Can you see my screen with a
ribbon diagram moving around?
All right. Excellent.
So this is a structure I shared with you
in that email as well.
And this is basically a nucleosome.
All right. So that's what it looks like.
If you look at the DNA
and if you look at how the
proteins are folded inside it.
Oh, sorry. Hold on.
I have a random incoming spam phone call.
So there are four histone types.
They're all folded together
into this beautiful ribbon structure.
And then there's a fifth histone type
which is called linker histone,
which sits just outside the nucleosome.
And basically every one
of them looks like this.
Now, histones also have tails.
And the tails are what's drawn
on that structure over there,
on that board over there.
But they can be modified inside
the core of the nucleosome
or it can be modified on the tails.
And these tails also,
they look like antennas
that sense stuff.
You can't see the tails in the structure,
simply because they are floppy.
They don't have a structure,
they're just everywhere.
They sample the environment.
To give you an example
of what an enzyme will look like
when it's reading or
writing these modifications,
here's another structure.
And this is a much
worse quality structure.
But it made big waves in
science when it was published.
This is a very important
complex called Polycomb.
I am not sure if you have heard of it.
But if you do study anything epigenetic,
you probably have heard about it.
So this is the nucleosome.
And this is another nucleosome.
And what this Polycomb complex does
is it senses a modification
on one nucleosome-
- [Student] It's still showing
the previous structure.
- Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. Hold on.
New share.
Ah, there we go. How about that?
Excellent. All right.
So here we go.
So we have two nucleosomes now.
I know why. it's because I
opened it in a different window.
And I'm still sharing the
same window. Okay, cool.
So this is the same ribbon diagram,
and it senses one nucleosome
here and then it reaches over.
And if you zoom all the way
in, you see this blue line?
That's the histone.
And then you don't really see it.
And then you see it again over here.
And that's a histone tail.
And this histone tail
is gonna get modified.
A methyl mark is gonna get put on it
by this enzyme that's shown
here in pink or magenta.
And this complex has at least
four different sub units.
They're very complicated.
There is probably five
more that come around
and do other things.
This complex is very heavily
mutated in some cancers,
including lymphomas.
And the mutations, just like
in this picture I showed you,
the mutations in lymphomas
all happen right here
in this catalytic center.
And this enzyme just goes crazy
and it starts putting mark
over and over and over again.
Normally, it's regulated.
And in lymphomas, it just goes nuts.
Now, Polycomb is very special,
and it's very historic,
and very interesting.
Because when it was discovered,
people actually didn't know about histones
and histone modifications.
It was discovered by a guy
and, actually, his wife.
I'm forgetting her name.
His last name was Louis. Her
last name was Louis, too.
They were screening fruit flies
for mutations that affected
their body patterning.
'Cause they were interested in regulation
of how our body pattern's specified.
How does fly know to grow six legs?
And how does it grow two
legs on each body segment
and not an extra pair of
wings and all that stuff.
And so he was looking for mutations
that change that pattern.
And he basically had flies
that have extra pair of wings,
extra pair of leg segments,
extra pair of abdominal segments.
He ended up winning a Nobel prize
for those studies, by the way.
And just by genetics, just by
crossing these flies together,
he figured out that there is a complex
of proteins that does something
to repress a set of genes.
He didn't know how it does it.
And I'll tell you another cool
story about it in a second.
And he called it Polycomb,
because the phenotype of these flies,
they had extra bristle
combs on their legs.
Who would notice an
extra bunch of bristles
on the legs of a fruit fly, right?
But the name stuck and we're
all stuck with that name.
And Polycomb is probably the
hottest enzymatic complex
in histone biology now.
But here's a super cool story.
So there is a repressor
complex in flies and humans,
that, in flies was identified
on a chromosome three,
I think on the band
nine of the chromosome.
And it's called SU(VAR)3-9.
SU(VAR) means suppressor of variegation.
It's a very genetic term.
It's just the screen type
in which this protein was identified, 3-9.
And here's the super cool part:
30 years later, they figured
out how that complex works.
Do you know what it does?
It modifies lysine on histone
three in position nine.
It's just a coincidence,
but it's super cool.
It's like hand of God-type
situation. SU(VAR)3-9.
And everybody who you talk
to you now, they're like,
"Oh, yeah. SU(VAR)3-9
because it's the histone H3
and lysine 9 methyltransferase."
No. No, no, no.
They named it 30 years before
they knew what it does.
And it's just an accident
that the name matches so well.
Anyway, so this is
what the enzymatic complex will look like.
And the structure was made
just about a year ago.
We finally have the tools
to do this kind of stuff.
So any more questions?
I'm gonna stop sharing this,
and I will get back to the screen.
- Do you think...
So our class, we just started
talking about protein folding
and stuff like that.
Can you tell us a little bit
about how you get a structure like that?
Like the one you just showed us?
- Okay, yeah. So there is two ways.
And there really has been...
I'm gonna keep sharing this
because it's just such
a beautiful structure.
Or I can just show you.
On the wall, there's a
cross-stitch of that structure too.
You probably can see it right over there.
My boss, his children are in the army.
And so we have like army and Navy walls,
but we also have cross-stitches
of random nucleosomes.
So there's two things in that question.
First is how does the protein
fold correctly in the cell?
And to be honest, we don't really know.
There is a lot of talk about chaperones.
And obviously chaperones
are super important.
There's a lot of proteins that come in
and make sure protein stays
in certain conformation during folding.
It becomes quite complex
when we're talking about
multi-protein structure.
For example, the nucleosome.
Because we have, essentially,
eight different proteins
that have to get together
in the right time, the right place.
What's curious about nucleosome
is that you can actually
purify histones from bacteria,
which we do routinely
in the lab every day.
And if you add them in the right order
with the fragment of DNA,
they will just fold
themselves into a nucleosome.
They know. How they know, I don't know.
But they find their partners,
and just energetically,
it seems like
there's this one absolutely
optimal confirmation
that you can then figure out.
You might have heard
about something super cool
that also happened in
the last couple of days.
There was a Google AI, Alpha...
I know Alpha Star
because I play StarCraft.
But Alpha something, that
apparently is approaching
what scientists can do experimentally.
Now, you can deduce domain structure
by just plugging that sequence
into that Google alpha AI system,
which is super scary and
also super duper cool.
I don't know, it's all neural
networks and stuff like this.
Machines are coming
for us. Like, they are.
So I'm gonna try
and figure out how to
share this thing again.
There we go.
So one question is, how do proteins know
how to solve this structure, right?
And somehow they do. We
don't know the answer.
Another question is,
how do scientists know
what this looks like?
And that I can tell you more about.
And the answer is, until very recently,
we did something called
x-ray crystallography.
And to do that, you have
to have very pure protein
and you have to figure out a condition
in which this very pure
protein will assemble
into, essentially,
what's a crystal, right?
A crystal is a packed unit where each cell
is attached to adjacent
cells in a stereotypical way.
So if you play with salt,
play with detergents,
play with solution amounts
and concentrations,
and usually people who do that,
they do it on a very large scale way.
They have robots doing that.
These robots just look like boxes.
So they're not like cool
robots from Futurama.
They're actually very boring robots.
And you have to put a
bunch of solutions in them,
and they pipettes tiny, tiny
droplets all these solutions,
and then you wait.
And then a month later,
you screen through these plates
and you look for crystals.
And if you're lucky, you
will have crystals growing.
And that means that
you're close to conditions
in which the proteins can crystallize.
This was also discovered a long time ago.
People who first discovered it, did it,
I think for hemoglobin.
And they also won a Nobel prize for it.
But what they did was that
they put a beam of x-ray,
and they do x-ray because x-ray
has much shorter wavelength.
And so if you put like regular light over,
obviously the distances between the atoms
in this structure are on
the order of angstroms.
So it's 1/10th of a nanometer.
It's very, very, very close.
You can sort of zoom in and I
can randomly color a sample.
So let's do a residue and we
can highlight the residue.
Hold on, I have Zoom interface over me.
Color, reds.
And we will show sticks.
So there we go.
So this looks like a tyrosine.
This is an amino acid.
Is that a tyrosine? I'm
gonna double check myself.
Yes, it is.
So this is a tyrosine.
And it has this ring.
And this ring has atomic density that
by shining x-ray light at the crystal,
you can collect the scatter pattern
and you can resolve that.
At first, they did it by
hand and it took years
to just match the dots to
possible distances between atoms.
And you couldn't really do it
with complex structures like this.
As time goes on, obviously,
we go from regular radio
to an iPhone 12G, whatever.
And now we can plug it into a computer,
and the computer does
the math much better than
a regular person can.
So that was x-ray.
The problem with x-ray crystallography
is actually a huge problem.
You have to have a
crystal and that's hard.
The biggest problem is not
the resolve the crystal.
You can resolve anything.
The problem is to grow it.
And the bigger your protein is
and the harder it is
to purify your protein,
the less chances are you're
gonna grow a crystal ever.
And people spend years and
years and years pursuing that
for some proteins and they
could never grow a crystal.
That's how science works, right?
You spend years doing something
and then it doesn't work.
It's actually quite sad and funny
when it's not happening to you, I guess.
But then a few years
ago, something happened,
and what happened again, was
this big data revolution.
And the big data came in
terms of image analysis.
And once people had the
capacity to analyze images
at an insane scale of millions
and millions of millions
of photographs at the same time.
It's the kind of the same software
that can do the facial recognition
and license plates
identification on the cars.
Happened at the same time.
They also realized that
they can take pictures
with electron microscope of the same beads
on the string I was telling you about.
So what you do is you take your proteins,
and it can be a very
large protein complex now.
It can be a protein complex
that's very hard to purify.
It doesn't matter.
You put a very thin layer on the slide,
and you plug it into the
cryo-electron microscope.
So at very, very cold temperatures,
the electron light, same
electron light shines
on these protein complexes
and you get the actual photograph.
And then you take these photographs
and you take millions...
Well, not millions, but tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of them,
you plug them into software.
Software starts figuring out,
are there any stereotypical patterns?
And the more photographs you take,
the more precise can software be.
And, actually, the
structure I was showing you
for the Polycomb complex,
that's how it was obtained.
So now, the electron
densities can be derived
from just the photograph.
And that has revolutionized
crystallography.
Everybody who is doing x-ray
crystals is now out of a job.
Not really, but they have
to change their ways.
And people who know how
to operate these cryo-electron microscopes
are absolutely top scientists and so on.
They won Nobel prizes for
that technology as well.
And now with Google AI on the way,
I think five years down the road,
they will be looking for jobs too.
So that's progress. That's how it works.
And that's quite exciting.
So that's how these
structures are derived.
What I personally do is I
then look at the structures.
I derived one structure in my lifetime,
that was very long time ago
when I was in graduate school.
It takes a long time.
It looks super cool, but
if you're working on this,
you're gonna spend months figuring out
if this atom was aligned
one way or slightly off.
And again, we're talking
about all of these maps,
all of these cool looking models.
They're essentially probabilities.
Like what we do is we say,
"Yeah, this is the likely structure.
Is it always like this? I don't know.
I'm not sure."
But that's where we're at.
What I was gonna tell you about?
I was gonna tell you
about cancer and histones.
And I can do that real quick.
I have 10 more minutes.
Or I can just walk you through the lab,
and I can show you our wet lab part,
which to be honest, in biochemistry labs,
they're quite boring.
There's nothing there that's like,
"Oh my god!" We don't have
this giant microscope.
But even if we did have
a giant microscope,
all you're gonna see is just the tubes
and the big white box.
So whatever you guys want.
I can talk for 10 more minutes
about histones and cancer,
or I can just walk you through the lab
with a cell phone and you
get to meet the lab mates.
So I'll stop the screen sharing again.
- [Student] I don't
really prefer either one.
I'd be fine with either.
- Lab tour. All right, lab tour, it is.
Lab tour wins.
Okay, stop the count. Lab tour.
(Alexey laughs)
I will unmute myself.
Can you guys hear me?
How do I switch the camera?
- [Odaelys] Yeah, we can hear you.
- [Alexey] All right. Excellent.
So now I will walk through the lab.
And this is basically the office space,
which every lab has in
its most important part.
And here is some equipments.
And here is a machine
that lets you calculate
how quickly your genes are expressed,
how many of them are expressed,
and what's the expression level.
It's called quantitative PCR.
There are some people working hard.
This is what a wet lab looks like.
And some of you might have seen a tank
or something called Western blot.
This is basically polyacrylamide gel.
It's a polyacrylamide gel that
you lower the protein into,
and then you apply a current.
And basically what happens,
the proteins run through
the polyacrylamide gel
at different speeds because
they're different sizes.
And then you can get them out of the gel
and identify them using (indiscernible).
Here's more lab.
I don't think anybody's working
with any gene pool right now.
The coolest thing we have done
in the lab is probably mouse work.
And here are other post-docs in the lab.
And here's our benches and our workspaces.
And to be honest,
the coolest part here is
just little centrifuges,
and occasional reagents, and
the occasional screwdriver.
Oh, look at that!
This is cell suspension. And
these cells will get spun down.
I don't think you can ever see the color.
So what are you gonna do with these cells?
(Alexey's colleague responds)
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
So that's exactly that.
We're gonna do Western blot.
We do a lot of Westerns in the lab.
These are shaker incubators,
where we grow bacteria.
You can grow with them at
different temperatures.
These are tanks where we store...
It's the masks. Yes.
So this is the temperature.
And this is super duper cool.
This is where we store the cells.
And it's liquid nitrogen.
Boom.
On -142.
This is the tissue culture.
It might get a little spotty
with the coverage here
because I think this is
where our network fails.
And this is what the cells look like
when we grow them in culture.
You can't actually see the
cells, but that's the plates,
and that's the (indiscernible)
And then this is where they live.
You can grow regular cells,
you can grow cancer cells.
And it looks really
dry, like a little rusty
but that's actually copper.
And copper is killing bacteria and fungi.
So the copper lining of the incubators
is actually quite good.
And I'm gonna show you
a couple more things
in another room.
And chances are, you guys
are gonna break off here
because we don't have any
coverage here on the network.
But here is the part of the lab
where we sometimes work
with radioactivity.
Like if you ever want to
trace a special protein
that you're interested in,
sometimes the easiest way to do so
is to put in radioactive
amino acid into it.
And then you can track it.
You'll always be able to find it.
I guess, I can't even open
this because it's frozen shut.
Very good.
And that's how you store that stuff.
Like this is not Chernobyl-level radiation
but it has still has to be
stored in a very special way.
So there's that.
We have to dispose of
radioactive materials
in a certain way.
So it goes into special containers
and it just lives there
until somebody picks them up.
These are centrifuges.
If you want to separate different proteins
or different parts of the cell,
you can spin them at...
Like this is the speed. So
that's rounds per minute.
That's how quickly the centrifuge will go.
You need a pretty strong motor and vacuum
and all this stuff.
And then there's a
bunch of other random...
Oh yeah, a washing machine.
So here's the funny thing about this.
Because when it works, this thing...
Like the rotor is spinning, obviously,
at a super high speed.
One thing you should never do
when the centrifuge is
spinning, is move it.
And it happens.
And actually...
I'm not sure if I...
I need to turn it on to open it.
If you look inside the rotor,
inside the chamber here,
there's this big bump in the chamber.
And that's because somebody
moved the centrifuge
when it was on, and the rotor just ran off
the axles it was spinning on,
and slammed into the wall.
It was a big disaster.
Well, disasters happen
in the lab all the time.
So these are machines,
again, to separate proteins.
This is called HPLC. It's
liquid chromatography.
You can separate more
than proteins using these,
but we use them for proteins.
So what happens, it's the
same principle as the gel
that we used for the Western blots.
But in this case, we inject
proteins into this machine,
and then they run through
of this little device.
It's a column with media.
And different proteins get
stuck at different times.
And so you start with a mix of proteins
but as you go, they go through the column.
For example, small proteins will go first,
large proteins will go last.
And then you can harvest these proteins
into these little tubes,
at different fractions,
and then you can isolate these fractions,
and do all kinds of science with them.
If you need to break...
Oh, yeah.
There we go. That's the view.
(Alexey laughs)
We don't get to look out
over the window very much,
but this is our view.
That's the view.
And that's the cold room.
That's where we store stuff.
That's where we do some experiments, too.
It's basically a big room
that's set to four degrees.
We have another one that
used to be set to 37 degrees,
but right now we just basically
turned into a storage room,
because we don't work with
these little ciliates anymore
that I told you about a while ago.
So I'm gonna switch to my own face.
No. Hold on.
There we go.
And I'm gonna return back to the office
because it is already 11 o'clock.
And I think you guys have
another class in about a minute,
or I don't know how
school works these days.
Yes. While I'm walking, come
up with a couple of questions.
Very educational.
Okay. I will turn this off.
If you guys like looking at the equipment,
wait until the pandemic
is over and come back,
come to actual labs.
The thing is thinking about lab equipment,
all equipment is the same in every lab.
You don't have to come to Rockefeller
to look at a centrifuge.
- I think Nora had a question
about how did you get into the field?
- Yeah, so I grew up in Russia.
I went to school there.
And then basically the choice was,
do I go to biology in
college or do I do medicine?
And then Russia's system
was completely different.
It's not like med school is
super prestigious or anything.
But, still, biology teachers make nothing
and doctors can can
make a little bit more.
And so I went to med school,
while not really wanting
to do medicine on.
And then when I was probably
my fourth year there
in med school, in Russia, I
basically got an internship
in a research lab in US.
And I came to the US for like
a little four month stint.
I almost failed my medical exams
because of that, in Russia,
because I missed like
four months out of a year.
And I loved it. I was super excited.
Actually, I did the
protein crystallography.
I was very happy to do that.
And I came back for grad
school two years later.
And I worked on fruit flies.
Studied fly o-genuses
And how the o-site is specified,
and how female fertility
sterility works in fruit flies.
And then after that, I realized that,
stuff that happens in the nucleus
is probably the most important part,
so I want to study that.
And if you want to study
stuff in the nucleus,
you really want to start with this.
And then I came here.
I think, as in colleges too,
you apply to multiple, different places.
You interview in
multiple, different places
and you basically see
what's the better fit.
I thought I would work on small RNAs.
When I was in college, microRNAs
and siRNAs were super hot.
Everybody loved small RNAs.
And I rotated in the
lab that studied them,
and I was like, "No, this is boring."
What I find boring, I'm sure
some people will be like,
"Oh my god, this is the most
exciting thing in the world."
So I'm not judging. I'm just
like, not for me at all.
Anything else?
Protein structure is important.
Enzymes are important.
Substrates are important.
Amino acids.
If you know that the difference
between lysine and glutamic acid,
you know more than most people.
So you got to know K's, R's,
E's, and D's, and that's all.
And also, you know, the
glycine breaks the alpha helix.
That's also cool.
If you put a glycine into the protein,
it will break the helix.
Yes. Centrifuges.
So when I worked in Russia,
we didn't have these nice centrifuges.
We had a plastic centrifuge
that it was really terrible.
But we figured out a
way how to isolate DNA
on the centrifuge, and we did that.
And I don't wish that upon
anyone. But we did that.
We washed the pipette tips,
and we washed the tubes, too.
That was hilarious.
I worked in a research
institute that the project was,
we studied tuberculosis
in HIV positive patients.
And we washed the tips and plastic
from our bio material.
Here, it would be like a
biosafety level three, probably.
You would need to wear a full
hazmat suit to work with that.
There it's like, "Ah, reuse it."
(Alexey laughs)
Wow.
That is not easy.
So you sequenced it or how...
How did you figure it out?
Wow.
So there's a lot of interesting
math with DNA, right?
DNA is only four base pairs
and it's the same base pairs
all across the animal kingdom.
There is one interesting
hint you can get very quickly
from DNA because some
organisms methylate their DNA
and some don't.
For example, if you work with humans,
like 10% of our cytosines are methylated.
They have methylcytosine instead.
Oh yeah. You can do specific
PCR primers, of course.
But for example, if you
work with fruit flies,
they don't have DNA methylation.
And so it's really funny
when people are trying
to use fruit flies as a model
for a lot of epigenetic processes.
And I love fruit flies, I worked
with them for a long time.
But you cannot always study
human stuff in fruit flies,
just because they don't have
the same regulatory systems.
But obviously if you realize
that you don't have DNA
methylation in your sample,
you know that this is not human DNA,
this is like fruit fly DNA
or something like that.
Another interesting question is,
if human genome is 3
billion base pairs long,
how long should the
primer be to be specific?
And you have two primers, right?
So you can do the math.
I can give you the answer, whatever.
It's actually quite interesting
because it's an important consideration.
Because when you do a
PCR from bacterial DNA
or especially bacterial plasmid,
which is 10,000 base pairs,
even a six base fragment
only really happens once.
When you do a PCR from a human DNA,
you really have to make sure
your primers are specific.
And that they're long enough
that they only happen only a
couple of times in the genome.
Because let's say they happen twice,
but you only get a product
if your primers are
in the same locus, if
they run into each other.
Yes. So the jelly line
substance, that's agarose gel.
Actually the guy who invented
this, I met him in person.
He was super old by then.
His name was Oliver Smithies.
He was like really funny, old dude.
He came up with the idea to
resolve DNA fragments in starch.
So he had like potato
starch or corn starch.
I think it was potato starch back then.
And he made this jelly,
and he put DNA in there
and applied current.
And you could see that
small fragments run faster
than big ones.
Again, because big ones...
Yup. Yeah.
So big ones get stuck,
and small ones just wiggled right through.
And then, as technology progressed,
they replaced the starch
gel, which is super fragile.
It breaks apart very quickly.
They replaced the starch
gel with agarose gel.
And agarose is obviously
much easier to work with.
You can make nice stuff
in shapes out of it.
Yeah, no. You guys are lucky.
You've seen all these things.
I first saw that when I was in
not so much even in college.
I came to the lab and I'm like,
"Oh my god, this is the ethidium DNA.
This is magic, it fluoresces. Super cool."
And then, of course, you don't
know all the precautions,
so you start looking at it
without the face shield.
And then you think, "Why
are my eyes itching?"
I know why they're itching.
Because I was looking at
the gels for 30 minutes.
When do you guys have to go?
I can keep talking forever.
Just let me know. Cut me off.
I don't hear anything. Is anybody talking?
- [Lecturer] Yeah. I mean,
technically our class is over.
Does anybody have any other
questions to finish up?
We have a double period,
so they don't have to.
- Ah, I see. Ah, okay, cool.
- [Lecturer] Yeah, we do like...
The first half is together,
and the second half is asynchronous.
- So where do you want to
be when you're finished?
There's a question in chat.
That is a great question.
To be honest, I don't know.
I'm applying for jobs right now.
And when I say I'm applying for jobs,
I'm applying for jobs in
academia as a lab head,
as a person who will run his own lab.
I just had an interview in England.
I just scheduled an interview in NIH,
National Institutes of Health.
We'll see how it goes.
This year has been really weird
because teaching universities
are essentially not hiring.
So the amount of jobs that
are out there are pretty...
But on the other hand, a lot of people
are not going on the job market this year.
So just might as well try it out.
I have a wife and I have two kids.
My wife is also a scientist.
She's a post-doc at NYU.
Just 30 blocks that way.
We have to coordinate
how we apply for jobs,
because if I get the job in England
and she stays in New York with...
Can we leave? Yeah, you
can feel free to leave.
I'm not clocking anybody's hours.
Yeah. So it's an interesting
stuff with academia.
I think the draw of academia
is that you're sort of your own boss.
You do your own things,
and you kind of make your own schedule.
The downside is that you
spend 25 plus years in school.
You're super overqualified.
And you know this one little thing better
than anybody else in the world,
but does anybody care?
That's another question, right?
And then do you make an impact too?
That's all something you ask yourself.
Like if you're studying
fruit fly o-genuses
for the rest of your life, does it matter?
And sometimes it does.
The guys who studied the
bacterial immunity systems, right?
They were like, "Oh, this is so cool.
We have this bacteria with
strange looking DNA sequences
that repeat themselves.
Let's call them clustered
repeats interspersed elements,
blah, blah, blah, something cool."
And then 10 years later,
somebody else was like,
"Wait a second. We can repurpose
that and edit human genome.
or any genome like this."
And all of a sudden, that's
the hottest thing in the world.
And this is super cool.
Why are fruit flies used so much?
That's a great question.
They are historical.
Louis the XIV, in his
court had fruit flies,
and they were looking at their eye color,
and that it was cool.
And, of course, Thomas Hunt
Morgan, the guy from Caltech
who used fruit flies.
He was a very prolific scientist.
And people he trained,
every single one of them
went to be Nobel prize winning
or deserving scientists,
who did fantastic job in fruit flies.
So basically, the basis
of our animal genetics
was laid out in fruit flies.
Why it was fruit flies and not
worms? Just the sheer luck.
He could have studied C elegans and worms.
He would have done it
in some other organisms.
It's a mix of history and just utility.
Flies are very useful.
The generation time is just 14 days.
They live, literally, on garbage.
Like the fly food is corn,
sugar, and yeast and water.
And you mix that and you boil
it and you pour it into vials.
And you can have that vial,
they live for 90 days,
you can watch them for a long enough time.
They propagate almost indefinitely.
It's very hard to kill them, literally.
You have to try very
hard to kill your flies.
I've done that accidentally.
So they're very useful models.
And also inertia, right?
By now, there is such a bank of mutants.
They're so well-characterized
that sometimes you want to
study something and you're like,
"I wonder if there is
a fly mutant for that."
And probably there is.
And you just go in and you figure out
what people already published on it.
And sometimes you inform
your decisions based on
on that mutant.
We do more mouse work,
because mice are a lot closer
to humans just in everything.
They have DNA methylation
among other things.
But now, with the next gen sequencing,
and I'm not sure if that
point really came across,
because I was talking very quickly.
What we base a lot of our hypothesis on
is just patient sequencing data.
There is enough resources
out there that you can go in
and just look up a specific type of cancer
or your favorite protein,
and you can find which
cancer it's mutated in.
Or which cancers have a mutation
in whatever else you want to study.
And for example, histone mutations,
something that happened
in the last 10 years,
less than 10 years,
is that they have
started finding mutations
in these very tails.
And very specific mutations.
Histones are very funny
because normally you
have one gene per protein
and that's like dogma.
So for most histones,
there's about between 13 and
15 genes for each histone.
So that makes histone
genetics very complicated
because you can just make
a null of knockout, right?
You have to make 15 knockouts,
sometimes on the same chromosome,
which just is impossible to do.
There are ways around it,
but it's very, very hard.
But what you can do now,
is you can just look at patient data sets
and that's your genetic.
That's your work bench, essentially,
instead of growing flies and
running these screens on flies.
You look at thousands
of cancers and you find,
Oh my god, this particular
residue is mutated
in like 90% of patients
with glioma for example.
And that's true.
This K27, lysine 27, on H3 tail.
I'm pointing at it.
I can't even find it right
now. I think it's old.
You can't even see it, but it's
there. It's on these tails.
It is mutated specifically to methionine
in patients with these gliomas.
And these are pediatric patients
which, invariably, it's a lethal cancer.
You can't cure it.
And since we found that
mutation in the last five years,
we've actually come very, very close
to figuring out what we can do to fix it.
So, you know, five more years,
we might be able to fix it.
It's not gonna help people who have it now
but it might help somebody
five, 10 years down the road.
And it all started with
the Louis experiments
with a fly with extra bristles on its leg.
So that's how it works.
And science is fun.
- [Lecturer] Well, I think
that's a great note to end on,
potentially, that science is fun.
And there are really cool things
that will come from this research
over the next several years.
So thank you so, so
much for talking to us,
and showing us around your lab.
We really appreciate it.
And yeah, thanks again then, students.
I will see you tomorrow.
- Thanks for being around.
And thanks for listening.
If you got like 1/10 of
what I rambled about,
that'd be fantastic.
So thank you.